so a new report blowing up the Biden
White House narrative on the Chinese spy
balloon according to reporting from NBC
News the Communist spycraft that saluted
across the entire United States was
indeed hovering over sensitive military
sites and sending secrets back to
Beijing in real time the news flies in
the face of what President Biden told
the American public at the time
do you regret not having insisted on
bringing it down sooner no I think the
total amount of
intelligence Gatherings going on by
every country around the world is
overwhelming and the idea that a balloon
could Traverse
break American airspace is uh
anyway
this is not a major breach
anyway it's just just not a major breach
I mean that was a weird moment when that
happened when the president said that I
think everybody was watching this
balloon floating across the country
Janine and now we're learning that it
was doing according to this NBC report
the Pentagon is pushing back on this to
be clear
it was doing according to them it was
doing figure eights yes over moms from
Air Base often Air Base where we have
our largest silos of intercontinental
ballistic missiles right so it somebody
needs to come clean here if this report
is accurate because this is highly
problematic and I also think that this
is around the time that you started to
see the former presidents numbers go up
because people wanted some action on
this issue and they felt I think very
unnerved by the lack of action well I
think everyone felt unnerved because all
you had to say was it's a Chinese spy
balloon or Chinese balloon and
everybody's back the hairs on the back
of their neck went up because it didn't
make sense that this was a something
that was checking the weather or the
climate and the amazing part of it is is
that it it when when NBC makes a
decision that they're going to go with
the story who confirmed it before they
decided to go with the story it had to
have been somewhat from the Pentagon it
had to have been someone who knew about
it and then the the issue is how dumb do
they think the American people are that
the Chinese that we are in this
political war with right now in this
economic war and there's talk of even
worse is just checking what our what our
weather is I spoke with someone today
who's in the military he said to me you
know Janine they have the ability uh the
Chinese that if they have a balloon they
can send uh information to a satellite
that then sends it to China and I said
well can we interfere with it sending it
to the satellite he said we have nothing
that can interfere with that he said so
in that regard whatever they were doing
we couldn't have stopped so my question
is it makes the most sense that it was
collecting information over the IC
intercontinental ballistic missile sites
so what have we done about it if we
found out if the NBC story is accurate
that they were collecting information in
real time over our military assets what
have we done about it did we pull back
our ambassador did we close an embassy
were there any consequences were there
any threats no the only thing we heard
was that Biden couldn't get Xi Jinping
on the phone and that uh I think it was
Colonel Lawson couldn't get his
counterpart on the phone either so you
know it's a very frightening situation
and then you find out about China and
Hunter and money you don't have to be a
rocket scientist on this you know Greg
recall at the time that the reason that
they said they couldn't shoot it down
was because it might land somewhere in
Montana and hurt somebody on the ground
so balance that against and you know
many people you know including Senator
Danes from Montana said look we can we
can make sure we're shooting this over
an area where we're not gonna have a
problem
um balance that against the potential
loss of Intel religions that was
gathered at that same time well you know
it's hard to talk about loss of
intelligence with Joe Biden
you know he's very frustrating he's more
frustrating than China as a country
because we know what to expect from
China but we can't expect anything from
Joe or depend on anything from Joe we
don't know what he might do or what I
mean it
I'm gonna say I gotta say the thing
that's more dangerous than this balloon
debacle is The Tick-Tock disaster this
is where I think China is brilliant so
two weeks ago we had this American
political unity in Banning Tick Tock it
was a really big thing you saw Democrats
Republicans and then all of a sudden
it's DOA it just stops and it's because
of the restrict act it's no longer about
it's no longer about Tick Tock it's
about these these vpns I won't get into
it they're virtual private networks but
we all do it I mean humans do it it's
not just China
so it's that that's the poison pill now
that's it that is about government
encroachment and not about China so
China is like already one step ahead of
us this has to be this had to have been
in the cards from the start China wins
do you see what I'm saying that he they
somehow got
this other thing going so we'll never
ban Tick Tock that's brilliant Harold
so I think a couple things one I think
Greg's point about Tick Tock is right I
differ with your conclusion I think this
makes it more likely uh that we
Institute some sort of ban on it for all
the reasons you enumerate I just don't
necessarily agree with your your
conclusion but it can't be through that
restrict act because that's it's not
just Tick Tock it's all these other
things right right so I think we have to
think about it more broadly than Tick
Tock I think when you think about how
the moral compass around how social
media was developed in this country and
we allowed those technologists to rush
into that and now the harms we see from
I've been on your show talking about the
mental health harms The Tick Tock and
for that matter other social media
platforms I don't trust the morality of
technologists around this and
um we are in a war with China on this
front anyone who suggested we're not in
the cold war with China I think is is
foolish when you think about their build
up their Navy and the South China Sea
when you think about the the stealing of
Ip over the many decades and obviously
what we're challenged with now in terms
of our info Gathering uh with what they
what they do with with Tick Tock these
are serious serious issues not to
mention the economics where they own so
much of our debt when you consider the
their involvement in Ukraine their
involvement in Africa in the Middle East
I'm troubled by this story I'm more
troubled by this story than some we've
talked about in a while uh in terms of
the administration and what they're
telling us and what they're not telling
us it seems as if the story changes as
more reporting comes out if that is
strategic because we don't want the
Chinese to understand what more we know
about them that's one thing but I am not
convinced that's not a settlement in
real time Jesse that um no that's why
I'm concerned that they weren't able to
get anything that they had shut down all
of the you know that a big Shield
essentially comes down over these ICBM
sites and we don't have to worry about
anything we just pull we pulled all the
plugs out of the wall and they got
nothing right and then today they're
asked about at the Pentagon and the uh
press secretary says like I can't really
confirm anything about that report when
your spouse comes home late and they
tell you one story
or they tell you 12 stories what makes
you more suspicious 12 and I have them
counted right here first they said it
was an accident and the wind took it
then they said Biden wanted to shoot it
down but was overruled then said they
couldn't shoot it down earlier because
it was too cold in Alaska and too
dangerous in Montana and then they said
the balloon didn't spy on us we spied on
the balloon that was my favorite then
they said yeah we just threw a blanket
over The Silo and they didn't get
anything and then they said China was
flowing balloons all over the place
under Trump but Biden's the big popper
and Biden just started shooting
everything out of the sky and then it
happened on these balloons right the
next one like Mom and Pop Eastern
Illinois Balloon Club deal yeah that's
right and then they got mad and said
blinken you can't go to dinner with the
Chinese and then they shot one down and
missed with the two million dollar
missile and then we found out that the
Biden family was taking Millions from
China but we were really mad if they
were going to send weapons to the
Russians oh actually now they are
sending weapons to the Russians but it's
really no big deal because it's only
guns so you're saying China I think I
think China's cheating and I think we
can't believe everything the Pentagon
tells us
so we'll leave it on that Eerie thought
hi winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now